yo it's benny the butcher i'm in the
building and it's the bootleg cave
podcast ah you know what it is
who like cat podcast bootleg cab show we
got a special guest in here my brother
man benny the butcher ah the butcher
coming always man welcome man what's
good man this is um
i don't know how many interviews we've
done at this point but a lot we did like
this is like the fourth one we've done
in two years it's just like we just
kicking it all the time yeah we was in
miami recently right right right was
that rollins rolling ladder was rolling
loud i was rolling out we gonna end up
doing one in a couple more months or
some [ __ ] anyway tana talk four yes sir
it's that season yeah man i'm ready it's
about time man
um
what makes like because you know your
tana talk series is obviously tana talk
three i think is the album that
definitively probably just changed your
trajectory as far as like attention and
paying attention to you
um and then plugs i met kind of
solidified all that attention you were
getting but like
you know what why was it time to follow
up tana talk three because that was 2018
where almost four years that was 2018.
uh that's why it's four years ago like
those those
represent chapters of my life and i'm
saying that
i was i was ready to uh open up another
chapter you know what i'm saying and
talk about what i've been going through
talk about what i've been experiencing
because i haven't gave i haven't gave
nobody
that since i've been here the first one
was my entrance right i'm saying so you
know i mean i'm talking a lot a lot
about like experiences in this [ __ ] i
mean
yo it's crazy because i i was telling
you like i actually got got a chance to
get an early listen to the album man um
i know why people are gonna watch this
and and uh
the album's not coming out for a while
right
uh i don't know if we could talk about
the date yet we're not gonna put it out
there but about a month from now
probably about a month months of change
or something hopefully
it was the other date that people
thought but right
probably probably happened in march now
yeah um
this might be your best body of work man
i don't say that like lightly
uh
man
you're first of all just
addressing a lot on this project
and it just feels
listen man i don't know how do you feel
about it i feel the same way i feel the
same way
it's just
uh
and i like i'm i'm with the details and
there's a lot of details in this [ __ ] uh
i'm i'm this is me with uh roc nation
this is me uh who made some money this
is me who i got to see a lot of people
true colors and i got to be a rapper you
know what i'm saying so i'm like this is
this is like the butcher on steroids it
really feels that way like um
the record that you know we've talked
about this record in the past but the 10
more crack commandments right right um
is crazy it's it's as good as everyone
is hoping it is right but you have diddy
doing ad-libs on this record right which
is so [ __ ] iconic
the fact you could have man shout out my
shout out diddy for doing that you know
what i'm saying because he don't got to
do that he did that [ __ ] made it more
authentic and you know that's my guy man
man yeah go get y'all some [ __ ]
daily owns what was like the best [ __ ]
that the origin of that relationship and
then
just the origin of like when did you say
okay i need diddy to do ad-libs on this
or was it his idea like what happened
man just uh putting that record together
i'm thinking like how could i make this
you know what i'm saying let me get let
me let me see what primo think the one
who made the original beat uh let me let
me see what did he think you know what
i'm saying he was he probably he heard
that [ __ ] a million times before it came
out the original one so let me see what
he thinking you know what i mean he was
[ __ ] with it in i'm like you know
what like let me ask him you know i mean
he was with it so like i said he didn't
have to do that you know what i mean uh
do it like i said man
those at the top like him
they take it out almost as a
responsibility for them to help guys
like me or look out you know what i'm
saying but you got to be my head you got
to be able to certain cloth they're not
just [ __ ] with anybody and they tell
you that like we don't [ __ ] with anybody
but you know what i mean so appreciate
them for doing that one of the
new commandments i'm just going to spoil
one of them
is one that is very necessary and that
stay the [ __ ] off instagram yeah yeah
yeah right
because nowadays we know every drug
dealer they're flossing on the [ __ ]
ground they're flossing on the internet
they're [ __ ] trapping on snapchat
they're doing all this [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
it's crazy they're just telling on
himself like
in real time it's wild and it's it's
it's it's funny because back in the day
when biggie did the ten crack
commandments it was there was but there
was just so much [ __ ] that he was saying
that was like very specific to that time
that you're like yes but that is one of
the ones and i was just like someone
needs to say this [ __ ] because [ __ ]
that's that's that's gotta be that's
gotta be like a rule and i'm saying you
can't be on there showing how you move
you know they'll do it they got like
departments that watch your [ __ ] i'm
saying so it's like
biggie didn't get and i'm saying he
didn't get a chance to to say nothing
about that because it wasn't it wasn't
even a thing back then so now it is i
feel like if you can't you can't do it
without it being authentic so hey that
got to be a rule and even if you're not
like trapping maybe you're
scamming or you're [ __ ] ppin or
whatever it is these [ __ ] are
getting caught up because it's like how
could you afford that 280 000
lamborghini truck
uh
that applies to the life you know what
i'm saying
yes like you want to show it off but
like you do you want to go to prison
i know you don't want to go to prison no
you don't want to be you're going to go
that much you don't want to do that man
nah the album is amazing man um thank
you i think you got a top five j
culver's ever from him
and uh stupid he was too but i think i
think uh
he got he got versus it just
just like that
but just being on the [ __ ] and then that
vibe because sometimes we don't always
get to catch our favorites and the vibe
that we appreciate them and and and love
them
i'm saying people who say that about me
you know what i'm saying when i when i
uh did the hit boy or when i did the
plugs i met too they're like yo uh i
mean they want to hear me and i'm saying
that they want to hear me a certain way
a lot of people want to hear bro like
that even though he probably feel like
he got [ __ ] like that i'm saying they
just went that's yeah i mean at least
like a recent remembrance i'm like this
is one of the best and cole went the
[ __ ] in on his album i loved his album
um that was my album of the year last
year shout out to cole but in general
like i feel like
you know when when you're calling you
know you're doing this benny record and
you hear the way you came on it because
i'm sure he heard your [ __ ] too
i mean yeah because he picks up where
your verse ends a bit you know
um
you got it he's got it you know it's
competition
man it's like
you're gonna play different in the
finals and you're gonna play the at the
rucker you know exactly and i love that
i love to beat be able to have the type
of
to bring something to the to the
to attract and make somebody wanna and
i'm saying to bring to bring something
crazy or bring something just as that
you know what i'm saying
because you know that's what we need as
artists i know i need that you know i
mean still sharp and still you know i
mean because we've seen people i've seen
people who don't be around the same
level uh as talent as them and and they
take a i mean they should take a hit
because they're not you know they
[ __ ] around like no i'll get back to
sharks around i'm saying so the video
just getting him to do a video is a big
deal man that's huge that means he
respects you that means and also for the
record cole's just doing what cole wants
to do nowadays that's it so if he's
doing something i'm assuming you didn't
pay him right he that [ __ ] no we we
don't know man like it's a mutual
respect it's something that he wanted to
do i don't think i just don't feel like
cole's the kind of guy who's doing
features for money if he does it he
[ __ ] with you yeah exactly that's why
he even said for a second he wasn't
[ __ ] with features because he don't
he don't do that [ __ ] like he he do it
for the people that he he want to do it
for it there's no he can put a dollar
amount on that [ __ ] rich's head that's
some real [ __ ] that is some real [ __ ] um
you know there's
my favorite song that i heard on the
project
ewan conway
tyson versali
yes sir
which should be the name of this [ __ ]
album you guys have talked about doing
that that should be the name of the
album that's crazy right
but this is a record
that to me is kind of like
so needed for griselda fans to hear
because
there's been all this fake
energy in the air griselda read it all
the message boards about exactly
and and um
you guys addressed so much of like
that [ __ ] like you guys are family at
the end of the day
there's no weird energy there's never
really been any right so it's like i
just thought that the way you guys
addressed all that [ __ ] together on that
on that song was [ __ ] dope and like
super much needed like
and that concept came up from
sitting in the studio
discussing who was better tyson
versus ali
and
my my thing was
you never know
it wasn't
meant for us to know
because they came from two different
eras
tyson uh looked up to ali
uh ali
admired tyson
and it's like this is my big buzz and
i'm not competing not saying we tyson i
mean they got their own legacies but
this big buzz right here i learned a lot
from this guy you know what i'm saying
so
when people say like yo
like that's i learned a lot of [ __ ] you
could never you know i mean like it's
it's literally the same thing
it's literally the same thing so
i just want people understand that when
that [ __ ] be killing [ __ ] and going
stupid i'd be like i'd be feeling like
that's me
i'm saying yeah i always tell i mean um
me and me and uh
a mutual friend of ours were talking and
it's like
at any given time over the last five
years
the best rappers alive have been
yourself khan
fred kendrick when he wants to step out
um
i mean those are really that's the four
i got right now um
but like two out of those four
our
home team
um
do you feel that way like at any given
time like you're the greatest rapper
alive
i sometimes when i'm in the booth and
i'm just and i'm gassing myself you know
what i'm saying but by the way i want to
throw pusha t in there because 2018 was
about four years ago and daytona was up
here so that's how i think about it
i know i'm up there with the top [ __ ]
i know i'm up there that's that's not a
question because that shit's important
to conway you know that
he gives a [ __ ] about that kind of [ __ ]
yeah he do he do as he should
uh i'm up there with the top [ __ ]
but
i think
me being who i am
and me being what i've been through and
how i
the [ __ ] that i talk about that
and my personality like that's a cheat
code you know what i'm saying because
i'm i don't even be talking like this
but i'm that [ __ ] in real life yeah
what i'm saying so it's like i'm not
saying i had this so i've done this it's
just like i'm a stand-up cool person
in real life people
genuinely like being around me in real
life you know what i'm saying i'm not i
don't whatever so it's like
well that helps you and i'm saying
people want to see me win people root
for me you know i'm saying people
genuinely like benny the butcher you
know also so that put me so that put my
name in conversation right then the
people will say it for you mm-hmm real
[ __ ] yeah it's a fact people will say it
for you for sure man conway gives a [ __ ]
though like give that man his respect or
he feels some type of way
he
he always been like that man he always
been like that and i feel like
i don't know man
dude like i put i put i put a list at
the year list out i think he was like
three on there
i had kissed number one he hit me like
yo what the [ __ ] kev
i'm like kahn's like come on man
i had to like
literally like i just called up
like explaining to him he's like no i
respect it i respect it and i'm like i
like that that's why you're conway
though that's why that's why you're
[ __ ] he's serious about that that's
why you're a jedi because you really
give a [ __ ]
and
like it like
it'll be hard for
anybody
to i'm saying if we just if we just
listening we just comparing this to that
it'll be real hard to pick somebody over
him you know what i'm saying i agree i
agree i'm not naming no names i'm not
saying if it was him and it could be a
lot of names he's just listening to
it'll be real hard is there um
you have so much going on uh we'll get
to the bsf album that's coming out soon
uh
but
is there ever gonna be the conway benny
tape
man i hope so i hope so he i got room
for it i don't know he won't have room
for when he finished i'm saying i know
you guys got [ __ ] busy schedules
you're running a label you talk about
he's running the label we talk about it
all the time even like
uh planning on starting it
i think we probably even started i think
it's maybe a song or two somewhere for
it got to be like six songs that's it
six to eight records man that's all i
gotta be that's all i gotta be that'd be
something light bro just throw it out
there something like man i think we
should just do it and just throw it out
as like a mixtape just me and him no
distributors there's no nothing straight
up finally and then [ __ ] do like a
collab merch the merch will go great man
if you guys
march will go crazy
real [ __ ] it's a half a million dollar
merch drop well that's a fact million
million
million
drop but that's something that we got to
do man
we're just clearing this [ __ ] up uh that
just that just leaves something
that's just another box we can check off
now you i was just telling you this in
the other room what i appreciate about
griselda first of all i appreciate the
fact that
you didn't really ever like uh
sign the shady you like built up your
equity
and we'll get to the death jam [ __ ] in a
second but like just in general griselda
the way that
we've only had two griselda albums come
out on shady
[Music]
the the group project
and and west side guns album
and finally we're gonna get conway's
official debut
in february i believe he's going to be
here next february 25th february 25th
[ __ ] crazy project by the way
um
but
to be able to sign somewhere and still
put stuff out independently now for
people who don't know you're on def jam
now
you need to deal with def jam yep um
but this album
this j cole song
which might end up being your biggest
song ever because cole's on it right you
just be honest like the streams might go
[ __ ] out of this world
it's on empire yeah still indy
what the [ __ ] going on how'd you break
the system man i mean it's like
i mean that's where the game at right
now you know i mean where
the underground [ __ ] with the industry
[ __ ] and i'm saying you see dudes like
babyface ray or
you know what i mean just
i could keep naming a whole bunch of
[ __ ] who just
like you know i mean so my thing is it's
like you obviously have to negotiate
that with def gym
but like tana talk four is a big album
for you so why the [ __ ] wouldn't they be
like nah we need that over here like
because
they [ __ ] with me and they trust me and
they believe in me it's about this it's
like
no
coming from my point of view i need to i
need to
i put my name on that paper you know i
owe
and i'm saying so it's like this i owe
obligations to them and they owe
obligations to me so to fulfill my
obligations i need to walk in there with
this uh tana talk four patcher already
on my cape i'm also assuming the tana
talk four thing was already worked out
with yeah and that's another thing guys
basically i'm just saying is that once
you explain to these people your plans
they they understand it you know what
i'm saying like okay you get what you
negotiate you get what you negotiate
they respect that you know what i mean
like okay you're gonna you're gonna do
that and then you're gonna come over
here like yeah trust me you know i'm
letting them know like i'm about to
smoke this and then i'm coming over here
i mean like how many albums do you owe
def jam
one that's it yeah
one
god man listen
shout out to my guy ben
what that's a beautiful thing what i'm
saying but you know it's it's
opportunities for us to do more you know
what i mean but and the bag had to be
stupid to even listen i mean i don't
know if you remember this like a year
ago you were sitting in there
and um you were thinking about you were
talking to a bunch of labels
and i was just telling you like bro
what is this label gonna do for you you
already have a song with their biggest
rapper right right
you already have a song with drake
you are about to be on a national tour
with russ so what can they do for you
besides give you money right and let's
be honest
if you just drop some merch or you just
do what you do not get the money the
money's gonna come right
so the bag had to be substantial for you
to consider going down that route yeah
definitely the bag was definitely great
and it's like i want to i want to be all
over you know what i'm saying i want to
be able to you already are
that's a fact but you know what i'm
trying to say i'm trying to cover the
[ __ ] mad man listen i understand that
i understand that and i hope that def
jam does that for you i hope they do too
my my suspicions are
you get that bag
and you're going to be like you know
what
i'm doing all this [ __ ] myself anyway
bro you're [ __ ] i'm telling you what
you what you have you i don't even think
you understand it bro like i know you
you know you're worth and i know you
know what you're worth but i'm just like
bro like
they would they should hire you nah
that's a fact they should hire you to
help them with their artists and and
it's and it's not all about the money
sometimes it's like for me this this was
another big incentive for me
is that i need to be in these rooms now
just think this is real [ __ ]
you're in the rooms
no no listen this is real [ __ ] i think i
was which draft was i watching and i saw
your [ __ ] i was like this
[ __ ]
did you say that uh yeah nba yeah draft
[ __ ] she was crazy you're at the [ __ ]
nation brunch you gotta think that all
right nba [ __ ] rock nation brunch
everything all off uh
my cousin's getting the record deal and
i'm saying that all off of that now also
offer your work as equality yeah what
you do yeah so imagine when but trust me
when you're in this business you know
that it was still a lot of people who
gave beneath that cold shoulder because
i wasn't the one with the [ __ ]
situation
that's a fact but [ __ ] them but
now i can get in certain rooms and i
could you know what i'm saying now
certain people gotta shake my hand you
know what i'm saying well this is me
benny trust me brother
i got love for you genuine love
and i hope that you're i hope that this
works
you're you're you're rich you're richer
it already hasn't worked that's what
exactly has already worked already but
all the [ __ ] we're talking about like
fam you got a song with drake you just
dropped a song with j cole independently
he did the [ __ ] video right right
[ __ ] the room you are the room that's a
fact
i'm gonna show you i'm gonna if someone
hit you that cold shoulder [ __ ] them
i'ma show you what i'm talking about
it's not even though it's not even like
rappers it's like business [ __ ]
it's certain things that i'm trying to
do i got movies coming out i know you're
on your acting [ __ ] we're gonna get to
that exactly you got the sports agency
sports agency like i got so much [ __ ]
that i'm trying to do that these moves
these moves don't even be about the
music a lot of times it'd be about my
next move you know what i'm saying so
hey chad's not checkers that's a fact
and to be honest with you i love
everybody at dev jam you know what i'm
saying good people and snoop's the man
yeah yeah you know what i'm saying and
and it's transparency over there and
it's all that and that's what i that's
what i needed before i did some [ __ ]
like that with a major label because i
could have done this years ago i saw
snoop was the closer i watched a little
bit of the breakfast club interview and
it seemed like snoop kind of closed the
deal he did he did and i'm saying what
does snoop say to you
cause listen snoop dogg is in my opinion
um
the most famous rapper of all time i'm
talking about fame right my grandma
knows who snoop is your grandma knows
who snoop is my grandma don't know who
drake is but my grandma knows who the
[ __ ] snoop is you know what i'm saying
like
snoop is
that [ __ ] right let's just be
clear
so
did you probably pull up to the compound
in inglewood yeah yeah i did that but i
pulled up i pulled up in uh
in manhattan somewhere
and he was in new york hell yeah wow and
we kicked it he just revived i did
that's when i did the record with him on
the algorithm yeah yeah murder music
record
and then we just we just linked and
exchanged numbers and we just kept
talking from there and he just put it in
perspective you know what i'm saying
because he just broke it down you know
with this business with his labels and
all that [ __ ] it just be real
corporatey and all that he just like
let's call him
that type of [ __ ] you know snoop is a uh
a treasure man right right right what
i'm saying i love [ __ ] like that he's
good i'm gonna show you what i'm what
i'm about to do with this [ __ ] over here
i'm gonna show you i mean they better
put you in the new def jam vendetta they
got to i'm the [ __ ] butcher
what can you i think there's going to be
a new they got to make a new one they're
crazy if they don't but if they do you
got to be in there with a [ __ ] with
the apron on bloody as [ __ ]
wow
wow
they're gonna make your sideburns extra
crazy i mean have some crazy like bsf
chains swinging
i mean crazy like the shits your
fatality will be a [ __ ] butcher now i
don't even think they had fatalities in
the first step jim vendetta i don't
think they did but we gonna eat some of
the new one but i'm ahead of [ __ ] like
i'm gonna have all the [ __ ] cleavers
just strapped up that should be crazy
now shout out to snoop dogg yo what up
man gotta interrupt this interview thank
you for watching uh shout out to my
bookie man hey my book you know super
bowl season is here if you want to get
in on the action maybe your team missed
the game it's all good because my
bookies double deposit bonus make sure
that you won't tons of exciting prop
bets are going down i love the prop bets
especially super bowl man you could just
put so much action on so much random
[ __ ] it's amazing hundreds of options to
make the super bowl the most exciting
one yet for you man look it's super bowl
56 it's going down sign up in my bookie
now right now use my promo code when you
sign up that's bootleg sign up using the
promo code bootleg and your first
deposit will be matched instantly now
that's up to a thousand dollars so
that's
a thousand dollars in free money up to
if you make a deposit they're gonna
match it instantly but you gotta use
that promo code bootleg look it's the
biggest game of the year so what are we
doing my bookie gives you everything you
need to get paid while watching the
super bowl we're talking about the
opening coin toss how about the national
anthem how about how many interceptions
is matthew stafford gonna throw to me
at least one right um look my bookie
they're giving you the chance to call
your own shot too right now this is dope
if you think you got the prop bet hook
up you could be featured on my bookie
all you got to do is comment on the my
bookie twitter page that's at my bookie
to get your prop bet featured do that
right now asap
whatever you into maybe jamar chase
anytime touchdown score
maybe sony michelle anytime touchdown
score he's [ __ ] garbage so the odds
on that got to be [ __ ] amazing how
about cam akers fumble that's gotta
happen that [ __ ] can't hold on
to the ball to save his life uh look
don't miss out head over to my bookie
right now and double your first deposit
up to a thousand dollars use the promo
code bootleg place your bets get ready
for unmatched excitement baby we're
talking about the super bowl bangles
rams let's get this [ __ ] money
mybookie.ag go sign up one more time use
my promo code bootleg and you will have
your deposit matched double your money
bet anything anytime anywhere with my
bookie um
how was it being at the greatest nfl
game i've watched in i don't know maybe
my entire life that was probably the
best i mean that's a top five game ever
but some some are saying it is the best
game ever chiefs first bills obviously
unfortunately you're good your bills
never got to touch the ball in overtime
but how was how was that experience
man it was dope it was heartbreaking
first and foremost though i can imagine
cause i'm a bills fan i ain't gonna see
the i ain't gonna i win to lose because
i was there
the the previous year
so
it was [ __ ] up but it took me about
two days after i got over this [ __ ] to
realize like yo
he was at one of the best games ever i'm
like then i'm dennis i'm like damn he
was there i was on the sidelines mm-hmm
i'm throwing the ball and [ __ ] i'm like
damn he was there so when they look back
at this [ __ ]
that's gonna be some good footage i felt
like you know how i felt like remember
when hammer was on the field
but dion you know what i'm saying that's
not that's how i felt i ain't gonna hold
you oh we're gonna look back and be like
yo john you were at the allen versus
mahomes not real [ __ ] i was there i was
there on the field chapter or whatever
because some guys are gonna be going out
of here i don't know how many years them
boys are going to be going at it but it
seems like
it's going to be a while and then joey
bro now you know
only for the chiefs to get [ __ ]
beat by the bengals the next week you
guys would have stomped
[ __ ] with we i felt like we would have
but we [ __ ] with the bengals because
you know what i'm saying they like
donated money uh
last year and [ __ ] to us really i'm
saying and the chiefs you know the
kansas city chiefs too they donated
money to us too after they after that
loss when you say donated money to us
who's us uh buffalo oh nice buffalo uh
like children's hospital oh okay okay
i'm like do you got a bsf charity i
don't know
uh [ __ ] like a half a million
dollars that's big bro shout out to hey
shout out yeah you know i like that too
because nowadays i feel like we always
see fans fighting in the crowd and it's
always like so man people treat sports
like gangs it'd be annoying to shoot you
because yo [ __ ] you we went to war with
the fans we sitting in a section is
there's nobody there we got 10 seats but
everybody else is kc fans right so it's
like man when they thought it was over
you know they was they was getting with
us but they seen us triumphantly come
back and then they did what they did and
came back so by the end of it like we
was going like yeah [ __ ] shut the [ __ ]
down shut up by the end of the game we
was hugging each other like nah that was
amazing it was like we respect y'all you
know what you know what you know what
they were saying they was like
by the looks of this
we gonna play y'all next year but at
home y'all gonna be at home doing this
for this game next year and i believe
him i believe him too um
bsf you guys dropped a compilation
already right uh you dropped the
gangster grills you joined you know what
i'm saying with drama and then we
dropped my boy rick hyde [ __ ] plates one
and place two and then he put his stuff
out with green lantern um
shout out to uh but so we are gonna so
the gangster grills obviously was kind
of more of a mixtape that there's gonna
be a bsf album coming in what april yeah
bsf album coming in april it's called
long live dj shay you know what i'm
saying r.i.p to dj yes sir yes sir i
mean but i got some i got some showman
[ __ ] going on over there i got my boy
fuego bates over there i got christina
mackey uh my boy love boat
uh
young world you know what i'm saying
there's so many dope artists that what
i'm trying to tell you when i get in
this i'm saying i'm just connecting dots
i'm just i got ray moon you know what
i'm saying i got dope artists so it's
like
you know we about to start just cooking
like i'm saying i'm doing these movies
about to release the uh you're gonna be
able to hear all the [ __ ] on
the uh on a compilation long-lived dj
shay okay on the album people are gonna
listen to this after the album comes out
you have a line about rappers whose
careers you made
do you know which line i'm talking about
um i said but i say uh i don't want no
credit
for the deals i negotiated careers i
co-created and drug dealers i negotiate
with drug dealers i associate with
you talk about that whose career did you
co-create
all right i'm not i'm not about to like
say name but
i'm just saying is that
you know griselda put
do what i mean do i gotta say and i mean
griselda put lifeblood
back in a certain genre of music this is
true
but i do think there's a few people
who's like who who like that benny
cosign has really helped course of
course and there's nothing wrong with
that because people helped me my [ __ ]
was created by west side gun and conway
and it's about what you do with the
opportunity so be honest with you
if some people get opportunities and do
[ __ ] with them so anybody who make your
moves off of an opportunity somebody
give it to them that's really ahead now
like you do your [ __ ] cause it was the
[ __ ] who was posted been capable of
doing it who ain't who dropped the ball
and it's [ __ ] who you didn't expect to
hold it down holding it down and they
flourish that's some real [ __ ] man
that's real um
how many okay you know you usually every
year just depends i guess how you're
feeling for the year but how many
projects are we getting from you this
year
ten to talk four i'm doing a bsf comp
[ __ ]
def jam debut album
to be honest with you do you you think i
should drop that this year i don't know
i'm asking i don't think so i mean if
you're gonna wait like conway it's gonna
come out in seven years i don't think so
i'll be ready i'll be ready top of the
year top of the year that's what i feel
like you have are you able to drop some
more independent [ __ ] though yeah yeah
okay so we might get another
and for okay look it's like this
you know we're gonna do the we're gonna
do the singles off the uh compilation
long live shade and then even with dev
jam
i could do some singles
it's not like i'm gonna go hide or
nothing i just do some [ __ ] to warm up
you know i mean so i'm assuming that
we're never gonna get the drake song
it's never gonna see the light of day um
and i don't know but you know what
probably not maybe just the moment
passed
that's what i think to be honest with
you that's what i really think i think
the moment passed but it's a dope song
it's so it's always songs like that the
thing about me did it leak
yeah hell yeah so it so people can go
listen to it people can go listen to it
it's damn near out this is a it's a dope
record but i think it might be more
opportunities to do [ __ ] and
people heard it most people who need to
hear they heard the record already you
know i've heard it i like the little
fake name they call it what they call it
uh buffalo something i don't know i just
heard it when you played it for me i i
just found out like you you that naked
no i found i i found that at elites
recently and i was like oh i had no idea
it leaked yeah the moment passed when
i'm saying everybody was hype about it
and [ __ ] like that but if we drop that
[ __ ] right now on dsp should've
should've gone crazy but just cause
people want to hear us together that's
the thing about me like people be
excited when i rap with people or other
people rat with me you know what i'm
saying that's what i learned from just
watching how this [ __ ] go
you had to be super happy for khan to
get the hove record right but i know how
important that is for you i know that's
a big deal for benny yeah yeah yeah to
get that whole feature
conway got it first that's a fact as he
should as he should right but i'm just
curious is there any more progress into
a benny and jay record
ever happening you're on rock nation
that should be that should count towards
something
but this is the thing i don't think
i don't think hoe feel like he got to do
records for everybody who want to you
know what i'm saying but but you're the
butcher
that's what everybody's saying
that's just not anybody
that's how everybody feel but
like i said people just be excited for
people to
ride with this [ __ ]
and i love that about i love that i love
that about my supporters and my fans
they want to see people right with me
um what i loved about the album is
obviously just look i'm gonna cut you
off
this little old me i might be here with
that drake record man well record with
you not on donda like white people
it's a little it's kind of crazy you're
not on dawn i didn't tell people
about that look at these people who look
at these names
and the only reason you weren't on donna
really was why because you didn't end up
making that wyoming trip with with
because because like what because what
happened with that i was i was i went
out there but uh i had to uh
[ __ ] i had to [ __ ] go home and do
some [ __ ] for my daughter to be honest
with you hey family first really just
like that i was in wyoming for two days
are you watching are you on pusha t's
album
okay i gotta just ask because you know
he's saying this helmet here i'm like
you know you we we might need that uh
that part two on that thing i i've been
i've been saying that i've been seeing
that like i said people people want
people to rap with me what
i must be that [ __ ] i ain't gonna hold
you man i must be that [ __ ] i'm about
to go i'm gonna go research myself i'm
gonna do my own research google and get
to looking at my accolades because
people be wanting to see people rap with
me man um
you have so much chemistry with
alchemist derringer
hip boy um
obviously
the dynamics all have to be very
different um
that was my guys yeah with this project
derringer and al handling the production
um
was that like
did they work together on beats on a lot
of this stuff
uh
[Music]
damn it's hard to answer that question
because i feel like they always work
together on beats
because i haven't seen them both in a
studio working on [ __ ] and al going
through [ __ ] there's like yeah that's
dope i mean vice versa so i don't feel
like have they produced a beat together
on this i don't think i could but i
think they like they do [ __ ] like that
all the time and i'm saying i recorded
over derringer tracks
with al in the room i recorded recorded
over all tracks with derringer in the
room so it's like it's a collective for
them they they most likely gonna
uh have a say so on how the records
the the playlist of the records i know
wes does that too you know what i'm
saying so
your uh
affiliation with hit boy
i'm hoping results in you and nas doing
something that would be dope
i feel like that is uh like killhouse no
i gotta i got a record i never played
that i got a record with uh knives that
that i never put out really yeah i
didn't know that boy he was gonna use a
burden of proof yeah so what the [ __ ]
that's the problem i need i gotta stop
saying this [ __ ] to people because they
gonna go crazy there's gonna be bitty
record with nas then people gonna be
asking me about that
that's what it'd be about that's burning
proof too coming soon i'll be telling
too much of my business in these
interviews letting people know what i
got going oh you got wreckers you got
[ __ ] meek mill records you got
records like i was like bro this guy's
got records with the biggest
[ __ ] alive are we gonna get him
this guy's just got a nos record tucked
like yeah you know i gotta i do got one
but now it's like it just uh didn't make
i guess that one i guess the nos verse
didn't make the cut huh
i don't know why i don't know why but i
feel like
something with esco would be crazy so i
would drink something will hold
something will push those are dudes i'm
fans of so that's why i speak about
doing features with all them [ __ ] i'm
saying
you know what i would like to hear and
this is going to sound so random
i think if nicki did some rap [ __ ] and
had like you and nicki might be kind of
tough bro because i'm thinking like when
source when nikki first benny the
butcher and nicki record when nikki
first came out she had the [ __ ] with
like camron and oh man yeah what listen
just imagine uh
a street
nicki and benny record everybody
everybody know that to go crazy
insane she's the greatest female rapper
of all times salute to her you see you
said you just signed a female right
christina mackey uh ray moon
they don't they like not like rapping
and [ __ ] they just it's going crazy
there's weight it's top 10 [ __ ] you know
i'm saying energetic type of music
christina's a rock star ray moon just
wavy you know what i'm saying my [ __ ]
fuego
fuego base he just
went crazy spitting bars like i love
this [ __ ] i love just like surround
myself about around a good great talent
yeah yeah um and then let's talk about
this cause we got some wheat that you
can purchase in l.a
this is brand new [ __ ] that's brand new
man make sure
yeah
this is uh that buffalotto buffalotto
but what i like about these they just
come ready to go [ __ ] come
ready to go i like them
what i'm saying uh am i doing this the
wrong way the thing going let me see i
don't [ __ ] know
they're like little little backwoods
just like that oh tiny little backwards
[ __ ] ain't opening i don't know
boom
oh yeah these are fire
yeah just for people to understand
there's tobacco in these so youtube
don't demonetize this video
uh
but yeah shout out to yeah you just got
your hands on everything how is the
sports agency thing going
man i love it man just going out
meeting new talent meeting new people
who are excited that i'm in because
they're fans of my music they're like
damn you doing what i'm doing you should
check this player out or you should we
should work together you shouldn't i
mean so i'm just learning a whole bunch
of [ __ ] just
uh just going to go see different
athletes and [ __ ] like that man uh the
big sports firm page
we just
proposing athletes that we looking under
shout out to my boy t warren i'm saying
he'd really want to hold that [ __ ] down
is there any um other
cause you know i was i was thinking like
with what you guys do with a merch
and how like
like
you know i know there's a there's
there's some people who do like just
like i think a tech nine right tech
you're familiar with strange music and
what they got going on in kansas city
i'm like man eventually like there's got
to be like a bsf headquarters like that
in buffalo where you guys just do
everyone's [ __ ] merch cut out the
middleman
yeah it was already we was we was
already talking about that and we do we
do uh
all of our artists merchant and i'm
saying i got it
i'm doing a deal with i did a deal with
uh
merch traffic you know what i'm saying
so we're doing that [ __ ] with them and
people tell me about that all the time
we did graph merch people already access
to do they merge all the functions
that's what i'm saying you guys should
do everyone's everyone's cat shout out
tony denise tell my boy tony de niro i'm
gonna be holding that [ __ ] down city boy
we but yo speaking of that [ __ ] oh my
goodness what is this interview coming
out
next week oh my goodness by then they're
gonna say you'll see this [ __ ] wait till
you it's gonna be out it's gonna be out
by now this valentine's day [ __ ] i got
merch drop
[ __ ] is crazy
i'm gonna have that [ __ ] on how hands on
are you with the designs
everything these sometimes two hands on
they'd be texting me put me in phone
calls i'm like y'all don't gotta ask me
to do that just go like that what i'm
saying but they run everything by me
because they throw with their job you
know what i'm saying fires cat and jake
they throw with their [ __ ] so they're
like they gonna run everything by me
like yo
cat dope i trust her to do what she do
but she still just hit me up and just
how you approve of this or what you
think and i think her as a uh
artist whatever you want to call her a
curator i feel like she gonna always
want to have my input to make it and i'm
saying authentic and what a lot of times
what i do is
i come to her ideas and say i want this
and i want that and i need that and she
had throw that [ __ ] together you know
what i'm saying but yeah you guys did
the the nike [ __ ] which was crazy just
on blank nike [ __ ] that was dope when i
seen that that was dope and they loved
that that was cat cat designed that that
last last year valentine's day yeah yeah
yeah all the uh
the plugs i met two [ __ ] yep she did the
plugs i met two [ __ ] i did the plugs one
[ __ ]
uh i'd be having to battle her to let
her know that i'm still raw with this
[ __ ] too because i can design some [ __ ]
too yeah i mean what was the wildest
thing you sold on tour this time because
i've seen you sell a [ __ ] like 300
butcher apron
the signed pyrex jars always are very
like what what what was the wildest
thing at the merch booth for the tour
that just ended
the wildest thing at the merge booth
basically is
you know i wear all whites right i
always wear all white air force horses
i get a bomb buying them shits ten at a
time
uh sometimes i get them custom made i
let my but i can put a little gator
ostrich nike [ __ ] on right so
we i get them and i throw them out you
know people can't believe that's like yo
you throw them shits out after you wear
them and it's different it's not like
it's not like i'm super rich or nothing
it's like this it's like you know we buy
thousand dollar shoes or 300 dollar
shoes so if you get if you get three
hundred dollars for three pairs of shoes
like that's a still you know what i'm
saying or whatever i might wear them
like two days at the most right uh so
check this out
people like [ __ ] if we not throwing
these out we're we you gonna sign these
[ __ ] we're gonna put them at
the merch table and you'll sell them for
three four five hundred dollars so you
were selling
previously worn signed air force if i
performed and if i performed in seattle
and the next show was in portland the
port the seattle shoes were on sale yup
yup and they were people buy them oh
every every [ __ ] night they bought
them wow
that's amazing hey i like that real [ __ ]
someone
yeah that's that's kind of wild though i
was like yo i got some used shoes these
are these were bennies man
i think that's dope man i think that's
dope i ain't like cell like is it kind
of weird having like most of your guys
is really hardcore fans are very very
very serious fans and most of them are
dudes right right is it like what's it
like having like you know drake's got to
deal with like a million women
you go to a gerzelda show there's some
there's some chicks in there
but you know the hardcore griselda fans
are mostly dudes is it like weird
dealing with like dudes that are
obsessed with you on a on a you know
there's a lot of guys i don't even mean
that in a gay way i just mean that in
like some fandom [ __ ] like nah nah
they just be fans they just you're like
you probably i'm sure like like people
follow you to ten different dates and
all kinds of wild ass [ __ ] that's dope i
think it is dope but like it's different
right like but i never thought about it
like that you know what i'm saying like
man these dudes follow me but it'd just
be because it'd be cool you would be
having your [ __ ] face tattooed on
them and [ __ ]
that's crazy i ain't never seen that but
it's like my boy man he got the bsf
tattoo i'm saying my other boy he got
the [ __ ] the benny the butcher [ __ ] i
ended up like i got a tattoo like i
copied the fan i've seen a fan get it
clear because i said i'm gonna go get
that [ __ ] too you know what i'm saying
so i think that's dope and
that's just
it's crazy though it's but i don't look
at it as weird but i look at it as like
it is crazy that i'm like you guys have
like a crazy reddit thread are you
familiar with the griselda reddit
please don't put me under that because i
know they'd be saying crazy [ __ ] yo
griselda reddit is like the it's like
the qa none for gezelda fans
[ __ ] be covered up with their
own wild ass theories in there it's like
it's
it's it's wild yeah well man shout out
and plus these dudes be doctors and
lawyers and [ __ ] they don't be young and
i mean so that that's be the most
interesting part like they'd be like
upstanding citizens and [ __ ] maybe
coming to this [ __ ] how are you you know
what that do you know what that doodle
what i thought about it when you asked
me that
that's why
our name was in these conversations
because it's like mostly guys who's
having these conversations this is true
ain't no females no we're like the best
rapper or if they are they get in a
conversation they're not igniting the
conversation right right right so i
think that got something to do with it
too hey we gotta stop the podcast man
real quick appreciate y'all for watching
uh really mean mean it subscribe like
leave a comment even if you're one of
those [ __ ] who leaves a comment
you're always interrupting the guests
cause it's my [ __ ] podcast i don't
know i like to talk too
anyway
hey shout out to odd socks man they've
been our sponsor from day one we go hard
for odd socks always man literally go
hard for my wife and i go hard for odd
socks
in different and same kinds of ways you
know what i'm saying sometimes i go hard
in odd socks
they do make boxers
you feel me
anyway um listen they got the ill
licenses they got the breaking bad they
got the wwe they got mountain dew they
got [ __ ] swedish fish [ __ ]
kool-aid
uh
pez you know
cheech and chong what are you into the
odd socks basics are the boys though
that's my favorite you know you get
yourself a nice pair of just basics
they're comfy it's like walking on
clouds all right so you can save 20 off
if you go to oddsoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg kev that's
one word bootleg kev
all together
at checkout 20 off oddssoxoficial.com go
show some love and let's get back to the
interview how are you doing
in terms of are you fully recovered from
the shooting now because i know you were
you know obviously you've been without
the cane for a long time you've been
performing and all that but you like is
your walk normal all the way now do you
still get have go through any pain or
anything uh as far as pain i don't go
through no more pain i haven't gone
through no pain in a minute
but
my [ __ ] i definitely got my limp still
i'm definitely still like waiting for
like
certain nerves and [ __ ] to come back
it's like you wouldn't hoop right now no
hell night who i don't know who been i
ain't don't know who but no no uh no
[ __ ] like that was that was it tough to
to uh do the tour like was it a little
different to kind of like maneuver on
stage than usual hell yeah [ __ ] it way
different but
it was it wasn't it wasn't hard as i
thought it was going to be to be honest
with you
and
i and i learned and i strengthened my
[ __ ] up so much from tor being on it
every night and i'm saying it's like
people
people can't tell people people don't
know no more like basically people be
like oh you good you you look like you
walking regular i'm like no [ __ ] i'm
i'm still going through my [ __ ] but you
really can't tell if you look at me
though um i always was wondered this um
there's a song that you address this on
but it's never going to come out
unfortunately how did you feel about uh
makhami coming back into the griselda
fold after you know the issues that were
kind of public obviously and you know
what were your thoughts on on him coming
back into the into the fold as far as
just being signed to the label putting
out prey for haiti all that you know uh
to be honest with you i i didn't care
you know what i'm saying i didn't care
i know you know that's what that's what
wes
that's what wes does like he he putting
albums together i know he
he liked mock him him and mock
relationship that's what they and i'm
saying i i know him only through outside
gun so i know that's what wes always
wanted to work with him so when he got
his [ __ ] together and you know i mean
like
i don't know like
i ain't you know what i mean i know
people [ __ ] with this album but you know
what i mean
is there ever a po like
with griselda with gun
could you ever see a point in time where
let's say
you're not on griselda anymore obviously
your family obviously you're still going
to represent that [ __ ] but like
contractually
like is that is that something that like
you could see eventually happening or is
it kind of just like hey look this is
how i got here
we riding this [ __ ] to the wheels
falloff type situation i'm benny the
butcher gonna always be griselda a
hundred percent
i'm gonna always beat griselda because
it's like
even just even if i'm at a different
label whatever i'm just going to always
be griselda you know what i'm saying
it's like
we is griselda what we built and what we
put together or it's not like
[ __ ] ain't gonna do what was she gonna
do two or three or four like [ __ ] like
that is you can always expect that like
if anybody go anywhere it ain't like oh
we ain't working together it's still the
formula 100 and like i feel like you
guys are like um
very much like
i don't know pick a [ __ ] nba dynasty
you know
we like west side gun is phil jackson
you know what i'm saying west side guns
phil jackson and kobe and kobe and shaq
is you and conway it's um you know what
i'm saying it's like
it's like it's always the best with
y'all
always always that's why you're going
you always going to have a con that
benny conway album
people don't know but people who've been
listening to me i built my [ __ ] up off
the bendy the butcher conway songs when
i put my first brick out in 2016 when
they had when they was doing the
underground run he was on my [ __ ] three
times
you know what i'm saying so i'll be on
like he call it he come get me for those
type of records like
always that tyson versus ali always i
feed off of [ __ ] like that then you got
gun on the album um
shout out to gun
i don't know if what i heard is even
going to make the project or not but
it's guns there's a record on their guns
talking some [ __ ] he's he's on some dj
khaled
[ __ ] ric flair ass
he talking some [ __ ] man paulie heyman
type [ __ ] that's how i love buzz man
buzz i love butt huh
yeah yeah that's what he do man does he
try to convince you to move to arizona
yet
boss i'm trying to tell you
definitely he was like man cav
i love it here that's my hometown so i'm
like yo whatever you do he's like we're
gonna build a compound out here inviting
me out there a couple times i'm saying
just don't if you come during the summer
you might hate it it's so hot bro it's
120 degrees are you kidding me it's
[ __ ] miserable it's like
it's terrible
you could like crack an egg on the
street and it'll cook
you get a third degree burn from the
seat belt getting in the car just [ __ ]
i'm a buffalo [ __ ] yeah i don't know i
mean no we
we use we we being igloos around this
[ __ ] time it was a big storm
like a couple weeks ago shout out to
buffalo man i did you know it's crazy
because like when i went to buffalo i
really i got it it was there for a few
days too yeah buffalo was chill
it was very much uh
i got i i feel like i understood y'all
more everybody
yeah
cause i was like on conway's block and
uh we went to the house that uh gunn
grew up in
um and uh i was like okay this is i get
it now like i understand like
when you guys say uh when when conway
said buffalo's the murder capital of the
country check the numbers and stats or
whatever on that jit song i was like i i
was there i believe it so pretty [ __ ]
you know it's a place that needs a lot
of love a lot of rebuilding it feels
like there's a lot of shut down
businesses
it's like dude i've never seen somebody
run a city like that though like no
matter where we went it was bsf it was
benny merch it was griselda merch it was
everywhere we went man that's back home
man bro billboards [ __ ] people just
walking down the street like i've never
seen somebody run a city like that like
yo like you see how the bills mafia is
they like that because it's like man
like they have nothing to root for the
new era store disappointed me though
wow side note the new the newer store
was terrible but anyway uh no they got
to get you the tour i'm saying you gotta
get the tour and walk thank you the tour
yeah whatever they had in that [ __ ]
front room was terrible
but now but you were saying they need
people to root for it yes they do man
you know what i'm saying it's like it's
a place like that so anytime we get
somebody to to root for a champion on we
gonna do it especially if they for the
hometown how do you got to chop it up
with josh allen at all
that's like the guy you want to like you
gotta get that's josh honestly i don't
need to be bothering him i need to we
need a champion just like tom brady but
you know like that touchdown's tom brady
you know he is man i might tarnish his
reputation like i just want to be your
friend bro
he might i might tie this reputation
like yo josh allen one night is that
because
hanging out with in the studio
with benny the butcher
that'd be pretty crazy you get him to do
a [ __ ] skit on an album what
[Laughter]
the
boy is not trying to a person like him
or you get kelly on a skit he need that
he needed that mahomes contract man oh
it's coming they're minutes they don't
want him he can't be in no studio with
me they're going like now we can pay him
that money you got to get out the studio
with the butch you in the studio with
bsf griselda come on man for real it's a
good place to be um all right so
he probably ended up being there anyway
but the people who paying him can't know
so we've established there's at least
two projects coming out the rest of the
year that's a fact maybe more
maybe more uh features uh
any features that you're super excited
about that you you've been able to link
with
because you're kind of it is but i can't
i'll be one because i'd be so
transparent talking about this [ __ ] and
then it should be everywhere sometimes
songs gonna be coming out it's some [ __ ]
that i'm i'm proud about like damn we
got to do that that's crazy nah i feel
like um i'm gonna tell you where we turn
this [ __ ] off okay no you you just in
general i feel like the last two years
have been like every rapper's go to i
need a real rapper on my song i am i am
i ain't gonna i ain't gonna hold you
something like oh look benny's benny's
on the album oh [ __ ] benny's on the
album oh [ __ ] benny did a song with this
person it's fun man and it's fun and
that just let me know that man these
guys respect me there's all been guys
who i respect for sure you know what i'm
saying it all has been guys who hustlers
and i just love being that being that in
that uh pocket where you know me
um the russ chomp 2 was fired she was
fired yeah talk about russ because russ
is someone to put his arm around you
very early um
this is before burden of proof this is
before a lot of [ __ ] happened this is uh
after plugs i met right yep um
i think man chomp 2 is so [ __ ]
incredible i'm like this people us
i love his competitive spirit like i
love he cares so much he's a demon for
sure and his work ethic is crazy he like
me he want to rap with the rappers he
like me
because he want to show like
like what we doing what are we doing and
and russ is dope he a hustler you know
what i'm saying that's my boy like you
said he reached down early man i
appreciate that was [ __ ] with me
are you um are there any bigger tours
that you're looking to try to hop on or
yeah yeah yeah uh
really right now they offer me some
tours [ __ ] right now matter of fact i'm
going to dinner with a booking agency
right after this [ __ ] they trying to put
some shits together but man i want some
i want some different [ __ ] than what
i've been doing i'm saying i want to do
some different [ __ ] some bigger [ __ ]
some i'm saying some more uh theatrical
[ __ ] so i'm chilling for a while what do
you think is the biggest misconception
about benny the butcher
damn
the biggest misconception without me
think about this one because it's a good
question
oh man
i don't i don't understand i don't think
people understand that
how hard i had to work for this [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying like i come in with
wes i come in with car way
i don't think a lot of people understand
that i
that i i
put put aside a lot of [ __ ] i got to
work so hard for this [ __ ] i don't think
i don't know man it's just a whole bunch
of [ __ ] i don't think people
really understand that you know i came
from
i came from that cloth i was 18 in
federal prison i was going to say you
came from being in prison not knowing
you know what i'm saying like people
understand that you know what i mean
because not saying that these dudes
these
guys and my peers ain't never done that
because we all just say we all be doing
that not glorifying enough but
you know i'm i'm i'm a real member not
saying that
i'm the toughest army because that's
that's that's not what i stand on but
i'm a real member man you know my mom i
eight kids
my main single mom been through foster
homes
and i mean and just just with that i'm
not a [ __ ] who got lucky with a song
you know what i mean like works man
exactly so it's like all of that
and and i studied this [ __ ]
and i mean i studied how to get on
because i didn't you know said
everything fell into place but i studied
like
like rapping i always listened to this
[ __ ] i wrote bars down other rappers i'm
saying just basically like i supposed to
be here and i'm a person we got here
like purely from the work from the work
not no luck [ __ ] no nothing and
sacrifice
exactly because i can only imagine being
like perceived as like
you know when gunn and conway were going
to those stations and you would rap it's
time i mean you got children bro like
you're a grown ass man you ain't some
kid who ain't got [ __ ]
responsibilities and [ __ ] that [ __ ]
ain't paying you at the moment
that's a fact that's a lot of sacrifice
man i
i remember telling i remember because i
always held it down for my kids they
always call and ask for [ __ ] i remember
when i was
really about to
buckle down to do this
i had they was calling me had to
tell their mom like yo let them have a
talk with them and let them know like
they can't be called me asking me for
[ __ ] right now because i'm focusing on
some things i'm going through something
cause i i didn't want to tell them but
they needed to know you know i'm saying
so they eased up off me
uh she told them and i'm saying in about
like six months it was it was i was back
in a position where i was doing [ __ ] for
him but like but it took like you had to
like real [ __ ] like that you know what i
mean
that's [ __ ] crazy when what was the
last time
you had a job like when was that time
where you finally quit quit your job
like what was that job like
that you actually were getting a
paycheck for
when
when i came home and
i came home in 2013. this was nine years
ago
i came home in 2013. i was
i just had
came back and i had one went on a
violation
so i went to like a violation program
willard and i came back
um i was only gone for five months but
after you you come home from
from a bed and then you come home for a
couple months and then you go back on
about then you come back it's like yeah
[ __ ] your ass down right so i wasn't
when i'm sitting down so i was really
falling back i was like going around the
hood and uh
i'm all [ __ ] like i signed up for
school
uh i met a good great nice wholesome
girl
and i'm saying she was my girlfriend at
the time she
she like
i was going to church with her
uh wow
and then like i went to uh i remember
she got her brother a job
like
like cleaning like the executive suites
at the bill stadium
and she pulled up to this [ __ ] and her
brother ain't come so she was like damn
like he was panicking like man the
brother ain't coming i mean and i liked
her so much i'm like i tell him i do it
you know you see that
and i worked it and i was clean so you
actually was at the bill's stadium we
talked
that's really what happened what i'm
saying that's what happened and now
you're in that [ __ ] in the suite
eating the food that's the fact on the
field that's a fact performing doing the
anthem the how crazy is that it's
[ __ ] beautiful man that [ __ ] like the
[ __ ] that's crazy bro well listen bro
i appreciate you pulling up tana talk
four
incredible incredible body of work man
appreciate you love coming up here
having these talks with you you know how
we kick off course of course psf almond
in april
tana talk four in march ah you know what
i'm saying let's [ __ ] go to butcher
coming let's go boom